we're going to talk about a really
powerful way to analyze circuits called
the node voltage method and before we
start talking about what this method is
we're going to talk about a new term
called a node voltage so far we already
have the idea of a an element has a
voltage across it and we refer to that
as a an element voltage or if it's part
of a circuit and it's a branch of a
circuit it we call the branch voltage
and that's a voltage that's associated
with a particular element so now we have
the idea of something called a node
voltage and this is still a voltage it's
not not anything strange but if we go
over to our circuit here and we label
the nodes let's start labeling the nodes
we'll call this node here where this
junction between this resistor and this
source we'll call this node one this is
the junction between these two
components here there's another node
that's these two resistors connected to
this current source and that's a single
distributed node so we'll call that node
two and out here these three components
are connected together in in Junction
and that's node three to define a node
voltage the first idea we need is to
define a reference node the idea of a
reference node
reference node a good choice for the
reference node is usually one that's
connected to the terminals of the power
sources or it's the node that's
connected to a lot of branches a lot of
elements in node 3 here is a good choice
for a reference node and the way we mark
that is with a symbol that looks like
this a ground symbol that's called
ground in this circuit you can there's
other kinds of ways to reference to
indicate a reference node that's a
common way you can draw one that looks
like it looks like the ground connected
to the ground sometimes you'll see it
with just an upside-down T like that
that's another way to draw a ground so
this symbol honest honest schematic
indicates the reference node and we've
picked a reference node to be node 3
down here so a node voltage is measured
between a node and the reference node in
our case we have this voltage here is
that voltage on node 1 the node voltage
unknown 1 we'll call it V 1 and this
voltage here is going to be called V 2
and in particular these voltages are
measured with respect to node 3 so
there's the minus and plus and minus and
plus we're going to use these node
voltages in the node voltage method so
first what I want to do I want to label
I want to label my my components here
we're going to call this V s and make it
15 volts this resistor is going to be R
1 and we'll give it a value of 4 K ohms
and we'll call this R 2 and we'll give
it a value of 2 K ohms this
is the same circuit that we analyzed
when we did application of the
fundamental laws in another video oh and
the last the last guy here is current
source is and we'll make that one three
milliamps
we've analyzed this circuit before we
used Kirchhoff's laws KVL and KCl to
figure out what the voltages and
currents were in the circuit we're going
to do the same analysis but this time
we're going to use what we call the node
voltage method and it's basically it's
the same application of the fundamental
laws we use Ohm's law Kirchhoff's laws
but it's in a really clever organized
way that is really efficient and I'm
whoever thought this up was was pretty
bright and I'm really glad that they
wrote it down and shared it with us what
I want to do first is just write down
what are the steps of this method this
method it's not a theory it's a method
so it's basically a sequence of steps
that you go through to analyze a circuit
and I'll write the list right here
first step is pick a reference node and
we already did that
the second step is to name the node
voltages
and we already did that we named our
nodes v1 that node there's v1 and that
node there's v2 with respect to the
reference node which is down there at
node 3 whenever you talk about node
voltages
there's always an assumption that one of
the nodes is a reference node okay the
third step solve the third step is to
solve the easy nodes
and I'll show you what that means in a
second the fourth step is to write KCl
kirchoff's current law equations and the
fifth step is to solve the equations
that's the node voltage method and we're
going to go through the rest of this
we've done the first two steps and now
we're going to solve what does it mean
to solve the EZ nodes the EZ nodes are
the ones that are connected directly to
a source that goes to the reference node
that's an example of an EZ node so v1 is
an easy node so let's let's solve for v1
v1 I can just by inspection I can say v1
is 15 volts so that's step three the
other notes not easy the other node has
lots of components and something
interesting is going on over here
so this was step three let's let's label
the steps here's the step one here's
step two and here's step three
now are ready to go to step four and let
me move up a little bit step four is
write the kirchoff's current law
equations directly from the circuit and
we're going to do this in a special way
but the current law we're going to
perform at this node here at node two
we're going to write the current law for
this and that means we've got to
identify the currents there's a current
we'll call that a current and that's a
current let me give some names to these
currents just to be clear we'll call
this one a one because it goes through
r1 we'll call this one here I two
because it goes through r2 and we'll
call this one this one is already is now
let's write Kirchhoff's current law just
in terms of I and we'll say all the
currents flowing into the node add up to
zero so these two have arrows going out
so they're going to get negative signs
when we write Kirchhoff's current law
let's do that right here and we write I
1 minus I 2 minus is equals to zero so
we're right now we're working on step
four and now we're going to do this is
the essence of the the node voltage
method this is where we do something new
that we haven't done before we're going
to write these currents in terms of the
node voltages so we can write I 1 I 1 is
current flowing this way through this
current i1 equals v1 minus v2 over r1
that's the current flowing in resistor
r1 in terms of node voltages the voltage
flow sorry the current flowing down
through i2 now we have to subtract i2 so
we just apply Ohm's law directly which
means that the current in i2 is equal to
v2 divided by r2 and the last current is
is minus is we'll just keep we'll write
that in terms of is like that and that
equals zero so this means this means we
have now completed step four that is KCl
written using the terminology of node
voltages and we can check off that we've
done step four